das schnitzel und dass ich zur berlinale
vieles dreht film stars wie tom cruise
cate blanchett jack nicholson jessica
alba oder robert de niro schwören darauf
in hollywood ist das berliner restaurant
borchardt als wird schnitzel place
bekannt
nicht nur zur berlinale geben sich die
stars hier die klinke in die hand
[Musik]
restaurantbetreiber roland marie weiß
genau was die stars wollen eher bewirtet
sie und schreibt darüber understatement
gehört zum guten ton
weil auch von uns mag hier so
monokulturen
das heißt wir müssen so gut und das ist
eigentlich schon alles
stars dabei sind wir wollen die nicht
ausschließen aber wir machen uns da ist
also das ist jetzt egal mensch ist
mensch vor allem zahlen alle gleich und
für alles zu schützen gleich groß ist
also im borchardt gehen mehrere hundert
schnitzel pro tag über den tresen
sieben tage die woche von mittags bis
spät in die nacht
rund 100 mitarbeiter sorgen dafür dass
alle wünsche der gäste erfüllt werden
das schnitzel wird im borchardt nach
traditioneller wiener art zubereitet an
den details wie dem perfektionsdruck der
panade wird aber kontinuierlich gefeilt
dafür dass defekte fleisch haben dass
wir bio eier haben dass wir den
hauseigenen hacker haben deren schlüssel
für unsere schnitzel produziert das
umsetzen vor dem schnitzel der
herstellung ist natürlich noch mal
besonders dass wir das in 80 prozent
butter schmalz und 20 geklärte butter
heraus packen
und da ist das nicht wichtig das ist
richtig stürmt und bei der richtigen
draht von 180 grad ausgelassen die
geschichte des borchert reicht bis ins
jahr 1851 zurück
zu ddr-zeiten weiß unter anderem ein
tanzlokal nach dem mauerfall stand das
zunächst leer
heute steht das borchardt für
weltoffenheit und internationales flair
und für die zahllosen prominenten die
hier ein- und ausgehen
bei der wiedereröffnung 1992 war das
nicht abzusehen
wir hatten schon ja offenbar war es
immer noch so dass wenn so ein trabi
oder im auto lang hier lang vor wiese
oppendorf ich bin dort groß geworden er
ist ja lange bevor die autos des fürsten
das war hier genauso es gab keine
geräusche keine menschen zur berlinale
ist im borchardt hochsaison
zehn tage lang ist alles ausgebucht wer
nicht reserviert hat muss warten egal ob
filmstar oder kinogänger
[Musik]
die gästeliste des borchert exklusiv wie
an keinem anderen ort in berlin
roland marie bekommt sie alle und alle
sind heiß auf das schnitzel place
[Musik]